If someone is trying to eat a low histamine diet,
is it okay to use the chocolate flavored greens first
or is that problematic?
But what you're getting in a scoop of the greens first,
how much cocoa you're getting in there?
I don't think that's a problem.
I don't think that's a problem at all.
There's not a list of much histamine in there.
I had the same question as them.
I really dislike the mid-flavor greens first.
We get that.
I understand that I personally like the mid-flavor.
Some people hate my son hates me.
So he uses the chocolate flavor and what he does at the show.
And it's nice that the chocolate flavor is the same price
because you felt the weight of the two jugs
that chocolate flavors twice is heavy.
So is there another brand that's just as good?
There's a lot of brands of greens out there
and believe me, we wanted to private label our old greens.
Honestly, the other stuff that I've tried
either just doesn't have the same about a stuff in it
and or it's just so awful tasty.
So when a company comes out,
hey, they said be a bottle of their greens.
They want me to try it.
And I just have stayed all these years.
We've stayed with greens first
because I just think it's the best product.
So again, I'm trying to use the best product for everybody
not just because we can private label.
We're trying to private label only the best products.
Well, greens first doesn't allow private labeling.
I'd rather use the better product.
So.